we are therefore calling on all levels
of government in canada to end all
coveted mandates and restrictions
we will continue our protest until we
see a clear plan for their elimination
premier scott moe of saskatchewan has
taken leadership in canada in ending
restrictions and mandates in that
province
hopefully these words will turn into
long lasting action
so far no one from the federal federal
provincial or municipal government has
spoken directly with us
instead they are using you the media to
portray us as racists misogynists and
even terrorists
as a woman with metis heritage
a mother and a grandmother i am offended
the reality is that members of this
freedom movement are average peace
loving and law-abiding citizens from all
walks of life
who are fed up with being disrespected
and bullied by our government
so on that i would like to just put
people's minds at ease
the public that is watching people that
have concerns over what they're seeing
in regards to the the heavy police
presence
all the different police services
different units
the barricades and
some of the equipment that people have
seen
i can assure you that that is all
standard practice
and it's no reason for panic any time we
have a massive event such as this such
as canada day downtown ottawa that's the
norm so
it's no it's no reason for alarm i
assure you
we have been working closely with the
ottawa police service the opp the rcmp
and the parliamentary protective service
right from
early last week
liaising with them
any uh
any information that we have received
related to any public safety concern has
been immediately forwarded
to the respective police services
because the
safety of the truckers
the ottawa public
the police and first responders is our
paramount concern
we've seen circulating messaging in the
media and social media
about people associated to the freedom
convoy 2022
being arrested and charged
i have it on very reliable information
that
people from the movement were not
associated
and that offenses related to property
damage and just an assault this morning
committed by agitators were witnessed
and reported by a trucker and one of our
volunteer security personnel
we also want to thank the thousands of
people who have so generously donated to
this protest to gofundme
over the last three days our accountants
and lawyers have been working hard to
deal with the legal details
this morning our lawyers sent gofundme
all the details that they have asked for
i am confident that gofundme now has all
the information needed to immediately
lift the suspension they put on our
campaign
i am hoping to hear from gofundme soon
so that we can get the money to the
truckers and keep our protest for
freedom moving forward
i will be providing regular updates
go fund me we've chatted with a number
of drivers i've heard reports of guys
that are already where there's money
being distributed to truckers regarding
focusing on fuel i've heard from a
couple people i've also heard from some
truckers that they don't know how to
access it just wondering if you can
clarify
for people wondering how the money will
be disseminated
and has money already started reaching
truckers who have made their way here
the bulk of the money is continually
held by gofundme
gofundme
because they were
bombarded
with a orchestrated social media and
other campaign to try and shut it down
or take it has
exercised heightened due diligence
which we welcome
and i can tell you that on monday
we took the steps to incorporate on
behalf of the freedom convoy
organization
a not-for-profit canada corporation
we've taken steps to
establish the appropriate
banking and other arrangements
and
all of the funds that have not yet made
it to that bank account are being held
in trust for the benefit of the movement
and
with the we have an accountant involved
we have lawyers involved all of the
legal and accounting
check box have occurred
there's audit procedures and so on in
place which will allow gofundme
to flow the funds
that so many have donated
once
once
once we
reach the point where gofundme has
released the the funds
the corporate
lawyer experts on the team as well as
the accountants are currently
refining
the process
for
truckers and others
who have been involved in the convoy and
are here now to be reimbursed and we
will be communicating that to them so
that they can make claims
so
thank you very much for coming
and
glad to have you come out today